one of the most peculiar ideas of
psychology is that emotional
difficulties can end up in the body
we can understand that a difficult event
might get lodged somewhere in the mind
but how and by what mechanism might a
difficulty get remembered or stuck in
our bodily selves can a kidney really
remember a sorrow could a wrist or a
femur hold on to the memory of a
punitive parent or a painful divorce
but mind and body are not impermeable
entities a lot of emotional traffic
flows between them when we are sad some
of the grief in our minds May well find
a home in our shoulders when we are
terrified some other fear from our
imaginations can grip onto our lower
vertebrae
the difficulty is that our organs lack
eloquence they are not by Design
particularly well suited to explaining
how terrible a relationship is or how
difficult it once was around our mother
are brains which have the immense
advantage of being directly tied to our
mouths have trouble enough letting on
what is going on inside them
most of what we are remains deeply
lodged in unconscious Darkness for their
part our bodily organs are even less
well suited to writing our psychological
biographies nevertheless if we can put
it this way the body has a conscience it
won't let certain things go if the
pathway to self-expression has been
blocked down the verbal route then there
may be no option but for certain
messages to be redirected through our
bodies bodily pain is hard to ignore and
that is the point we suffer certain
sorts of pain in our bodies when our
minds become far too ingenious at
overriding their own pulses of distress
we get into troubles because we are
Masters at looking past low-level
depression or chronic anxiety but when
the Deep self can't take our emotional
negligence any longer we may develop the
sort of backache that makes it
incontrovertible that something is very
wrong our stomach May well have to say
what our minds are keeping quiet about
our kidneys may have to give a voice
however ineloquent this may be to
troubles that have found no linguistic
Road out into the world
our bodies are liable to end up showing
far fewer symptoms of the sort that
doctors can't get to the bottom of the
more we can consciously understand our
background traumas the more we can speak
the less we will need to symptomize
through our bodies
a body can't ever really tell us more
than that something is wrong the next
bit the sifting the recollecting the
mourning and the interpreting has to be
done by the mind but we can say thank
you to our bodies for keeping us as it
were with great pain honest about what
we have gone through they are mute
historians in articulate historians but
historians nevertheless and the more we
can take the burden of memory off them
the less they may need to suffer in an
effort to help us to remember